MTV Films Scooter Braun is a 32 year old
talent manager he's Bieber's manager he
doesn't make films he got a producer
credit on this one movie which is a
documentary he should call his company
Scooter Braun film 53 seconds of logos
is this catfish movie uses famous viral
videos to get the audience smiling and
laughing ahead of the actual movie also
did that motherfucker just delete
surprise kidding Justin Bieber and Chris
Brown oh yeah Bieber started out on
YouTube I keep forgetting that because
I'm not reminded 12 times a day you
haven't
Rammstein sold out Madison Square Garden
and they're cool and all but it ain't
that hard if you're even a little bit
famous this motherfucking hand heart
gestures worth at least 20 sins on its
own I would write sins about this movie
as Scooter Braun would stop sucking his
own for five seconds
film partially shares its title with
that bull James Bond movie that was a
remake of Thunder ball also Bieber and
Vaughn don't quite go together shaken
but not quite stirred
the first songs that supposedly get us
revved up for Justin Bieber our cover of
Chris Brown's with you and Love Fool by
the cardigans see someone had to do a
score for the Bieber movie that's a
bitch-slap
that's not even at normal this girls
shoes if you do a Google search for
March 1st 1994 in order to find other
interesting things that happen on the
day Justin Bieber was born all you get
are pages talking about the day Justin
Bieber was born 5 out of 6 Bieber fans
have braces make of that whatever you
will documentary what is all this Justin
Bieber I want the music Sesame Street
and even Bieber's childhood had product
placement ball town people even trot off
for big for us yeah that deceptively
small Toronto blink and you'll miss
North America's fourth largest city his
dad and I split when he was about 10
months old I don't know how you expected
things to turn out when you married an
infant Justin is a dick to Oh Canada I
have serious doubts Justin hit this ball
you only heard the ping off-screen which
they could easily have added in post no
way Justin grew up in Canada and played
hockey
now this movie's just a Fantasyland
Justin is a dick to his teammates
wait Justin Bieber grew up becoming a
badass drummer and when did they decide
to switch gears and become a sellout
instead this asshole shirt I don't care
if he's being ironic that shirt just in
case you confused it with Toronto Japan
yes guitar it's a lefty left-handedness
mmm sweet tarts mmm Miller Lite I think
90% of my job is helping him become a
bit man then you sir have failed
I'm a 54 year old childless woman and
they call me mama
well that just seems cruel also Bieber's
tour crew is a dick to women without
children
why does Justin have a vocal coach when
he already knows everything there is to
know about music oh please tell me he's
gonna do what I think he's gonna do I
refuse to believe that anyone in
Bieber's entourage is a decent person as
long as Bieber continues to wear his
pants like this Bieber's dad's name's
Jeremy close-knit group chants the word
quite cliche the day I see boys to men
backing up Bieber that will be the
saddest day of my life and all the
preteen girls in the audience said who
tied oh man boys to men backing up your
son would barely get over it myself
these are collected no it's just Chuck
testa dude portrait mode and I hope you
have a daughter you're sending this to
because shooting from the chest is the
best way to make sure even Tyrion
Lannister can blockers hey asshole I
paid 125 dollars on StubHub to watch
this key concert you can sing Duke sucks
why the Macaulay Culkin of music the
Macaulay Culkin of music so he shaves
when he doesn't need to and he screams
when he opens his mouth
Bieber seems like such a cool dude here
but why do I still wanna punch him in
the face Snoop Dogg isn't smoking weed
in this scene seriously it's pretty easy
to sell out Madison Square Garden it's
in New York come on this doesn't happen
except everyone who's big enough to play
Madison Square Garden is this this guy
definitely lost a bet
Justin performs one song in his jammies
Bieber seems like such a cool dude here
but why do I still want to punch him in
the face Jaden Smith also karate expert
is that really the only legitimate
credit Jaden Smith can put on his resume
at this point in time Miley Cyrus isn't
embarrassing herself in this scene also
Miley Cyrus having a dad in the business
didn't hurt you either Justin needs to
chemistry books to learn chemistry
oh dude four out of ten is not alright
that's like 40% or something thank that
that's well here old kid I found on
YouTube he's gonna be in the garden
tomorrow remember it's all about Scooter
Braun and his never-ending selfishness
Will Smith isn't killing something made
a special effects in the scene then he
chase wears a velvet underground shirt
to a Bieber concert
it's like dinosaur Canyon Justin Bieber
knows what dinosaur pee tastes like
ladies were sorry to announce that the
New York Rangers need the venue tonight
so you'll be watching hockey instead
this woman find his identity and worse
not from what he can do from who he is
and for being extremely famous before he
finishes puberty singer yells the name
of the city he's performing in to get a
cheap round of applause legit terrible
lyricism
[Music]
Bieber Telegraph's the encore by not
playing his most famous song during the
main concert set all of the credits
aren't after credit scene forcing me to
watch the credits to a Justin Bieber
movie
[Music]
[Applause]
well my dear Lydia these fine love
should be multiplied not divided
[Music]
if the military is listening to this
broadcast they have to destroy this
building immediately before these
creatures can escape that's affirmative
let me spell it out for you I want you
to blow up Madison Square Garden
it was definitely challenging to be a
teenager and have to stay home while
your friends are going out
hey since fans so you know how we feel
about reading right reading but that
doesn't mean we're anti book if we can
get someone to read to us or find a book
on tape well choose there are tons of
stories we like that are out there in
book form audible is a great place for
you to head for audiobooks as they have
over 150,000 titles for you to choose
from maybe you want to go for full
synergy and pair something up with this
sins video well how about a Bieber book
hey they even have the ones mom wrote
narrated by his mom or maybe you want to
listen to one of the classics like one
of our all-time favorite books Lord of
the Flies written and read by William
Golding you can find these and other
great books at audible.com slash
cinemasins
that's right they gave us our own link
and everything so the least you could do
is head over there and pick up a book
you don't even have to pay for it least
not the first one you get one book free
with your 30 day trial membership
so check out audible.com slash
cinemasins today reading may be a sin
around here from time to time but
listening never is